gradient descent is the process by which
machines learn how to generate new faces
play hide and seek and even beat the
best humans at games like dota
but what exactly is gradient descent
to answer that question let's say you're
trying to train your computer to listen
to an audio file and recognize three
spoken commands based on a labeled data
set the first step is to formulate this
machine learning task as a mathematical
optimization problem
for example you can work with a neural
network whose weights are unknown
variables
whose input is an audio data and whose
output is a vector of size 3 where each
entry represents how much the neural
network thinks the audio corresponds to
each command then for each example in
the data set you compare the output of
the neural network to the ideal output
take the difference the square and then
the sum and you get the cost of a single
training example by taking the sum over
all training examples you get the
overall cost function and the problem
now becomes
how do we find the right value of theta
that makes this cost function as small
as possible
and this
is where the second step or gradient
descent comes in and you might ask why
do we need to invent an algorithm for
this at all can't we just plot the
function and point to the minimizer well
data usually has many more entries than
just two
and in that setting it's hard to see
what the function looks like
so what can we do
the insight of gradient descent is that
while we cannot get a look at the whole
function all at once we can easily
evaluate the cost function
at an arbitrary point
and with a process called back
propagation we can also evaluate the
negative gradient of this cos function
and take a small step in that direction
gradient descent continues in an
iterative fashion it computes the
negative gradient at the new point
takes a step in that direction and so on
and so forth the intuition behind every
step is that the gradient of a function
gives you the direction that increases
that function the most so by taking a
small step in the opposite direction you
can hope to make the function decrease
at each iteration gradient descent as i
just presented it is known as vanilla
gradient descent because several
variants have been developed throughout
the years to improve it
in stochastic gradient descent instead
of taking this sum over all training
examples when taking the gradient of the
cost function which can be expensive
when the number of examples is big we
can take a small random subset at each
iteration
adaptive gradient descent picks a
different step size for each component
of data
and this can be extremely useful when
data is parsed like text data and image
data
momentum gradient descent keeps track of
previously computed gradients to build
up momentum and accelerate conversions
to the minimizer this was great in
descent in under three minutes if you
liked the video like and subscribe and
see you next time
[Music]
you